was it difficult because of how
kanye became so public
kanye and i will always be family
at the end of the day i just want my
kids to
be happy and
healthy and
think the world of their dad and they do
kim kardashian wants her kids to see a
good example in their dad you just gotta
roll with it during abc news special the
kardashians the skim's founder opens up
about parenting amid her divorce from
kanye west they share four children
north saint chicago and song
kanye and i will always be family at the
end of the day i just want my kids to
be happy and
healthy and
think the world of their dad and they do
over the past couple months yay has been
airing their drama on social media and
trashing kim's boyfriend pete davidson
was it difficult because of how
kanye became so public how have you been
able to navigate that you want to take
the high road and sometimes it's hard
but i think that at the end of the day
everyone has their own way of
communicating and i i've always been
like a champion of him speaking his
truth and i would always want that while
she's mostly kept quiet about it kim is
now sharing what it's been like for
their kids and how do you talk to your
children
about it i'm really open and honest with
them you know the younger ones don't
understand as much but as far as with my
two older ones they know what's going on
and you have to just really
be there for them
no matter what even in this crazy life
that we live you just have to have a
really open dialogue with your children
this comes on the heels of new details
e.t is learning about the couple our
source says yay told kim he's going to
get help and has agreed to stop cyber
bullying pete the source adds yay told
kim he's not making any public
appearances and he will go away
somewhere to get better kim's new
interview echoes her latest sit-down
with alan i always
want my kids to just see the best of the
best
so i just try to as hard as it can be
sometimes i do try to ignore it and just
try to do whatever's best for the kids
that's what i love about you because
take the high road the reality star says
protecting the kids is her biggest
priority something both kim and sister
chloe say they learn from their own
parents divorce
i think that's just who i am and i
always saw such a good example in my mom
and my dad and their relationship so i'm
always just hopeful and no matter what
goes on you know it's the father my kids
i'll always be protective i think i
think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
[Music]